I remember we were shooting Ocean's 12
and Brad came up and said hey you want
to be in a Martin Scorsese movie because
Brad I don't know if you know produced
that and I thought Brad was joking I'm
like what actor do you ask that question
of who you know you're like shut up man
like he's like no I'm actually serious
and then he handed me the script and it
was fantastic that scene in the Elevate
you know what I mean it's just like just
electric when you're doing it because
you're doing it you know in front of
Martin Scorsese I can't wait to see you
explain this to a Suffolk County jury
you [__] [__] this is gonna be
[__] fun you know it was the the gag
there is that it's a total surprise and
I know I'm screwed and I'm begging for
you know I think I'm saying just kill me
and then the door opens and and his head
gets blown off
no one's ever gonna believe like that's
Leonardo DiCaprio just got his head
blown off like we knew that that
surprise was gonna was gonna work